so
my
i want to speak to you this morning
about an extraordinary resilience and
greater the american people
and american capitalism
our country is taking everything that
covet has a throw at us
and we've come back stronger
i'm pleased to report this morning but
many of you already know that america's
job machine is going stronger than ever
fueling a strong recovery and
opportunity
for hard-working women and men all
across this great country
america is back to work
today we learned that in january our
economy created
467 000 jobs
that's not all
we learned the job growth in november
and december over last year was revised
up by more than seven hundred thousand
jobs
on top of that
four hundred thousand jobs that
previously on top of the four hundred
thousand were previously reported
this morning's report caps off my first
year as president
and over that period
our economy created
6.6 million jobs
6.6 million jobs
you can't remember another year when so
many people went to work in this country
there's a reason
it never happened
take a look at the chart
you can look at the last all the way
back to president reagan
look how many jobs we've created in an
average per month this is uh it's never
happened before
and look
history's been made here
but it comes alongside the largest drop
in unemployment rate in a single year on
record
the largest reduction in childhood
poverty ever recorded in a single year
and the strongest economic growth this
country has seen in nearly 40 years
historic economic progress
and i'm proud of the role the
administration played in this economic
plan has played in the recovery
you know the rescue plan that democrats
passed to get the economy going again
the bipartisan infrastructure law has
started to get underway rebuilding
bridges roads highways ports airports
internet
there's so much more that we're doing as
well
and my decision at the outset of our
administration to buy america
it's always been the law it was very
seldom ever followed now it's a reality
not an empty promise
i made clear
that when the federal government spends
taxpayer dollars we buy american
products
american products made in america
including all the component parts of
that product with very few exceptions
with the support of the american private
sector our business leaders and
entrepreneurs our workers our union
leaders they've all come together like
never before in my days in washington
i know it hasn't been easy
i know that january was a very hard
month for many americans
and know that after almost two years
the physical and emotional weight of the
pandemic
has been incredibly difficult to bear
for so many people
but here's the good news
we have the tools to save lives and to
keep businesses open and keep schools
open
keep workers on the job and sustain this
historic economic comeback
vaccination and boosters have proven
incredibly effective
this past month we started mailing out
tens of millions of at-home tests to
deliver to your home for free
so you can determine whether or not you
have covet
that's in addition to the 20 000 sites
across america where you can get a test
in person for free to determine whether
or not you have covet
and we have more treatments today to
keep people out of the hospital
including life-saving anti-viral pills
which we purchased millions of
and now we're seeing the difference
over where our efforts have made
look at what's happened
just in the past three weeks today's
extraordinary job report that that data
was collected the cobot crisis
has been cut in half
down in half in just three weeks
still too many cases
still we have to be on the alert
but to be clear this is a dramatic
decline
now i want to be clear
even with the extraordinary news even
the historic economic progress we've
made across the past year we still have
a lot of work to do
making sure every american has a job is
a great start
but it's not the finish
for many americans wages are up this
year
in january wage increases we're strong
across the board and that's good
we have to continue to keep wages
growing
and we need even more high paying jobs
jobs you can raise the family on and
have some breathing room
two weeks ago the ceo of intel
pat gelsinger came to the white house to
announce a brand new 20 billion dollar
semiconductor factory they call it a
campus outside of columbus ohio
it's going to create 7 000 jobs just
constructing the facility
and 3 000 permanent jobs running the
facility with an average salary of 135
000
these semiconductors or microchips
power virtually everything in our
everyday lives
from our cell phones the automobiles the
refrigerators the internet the electric
grid
without semiconductors these things do
not function in a modern economy
so the spin-off of this is going to
create thousands of additional jobs as
well helping us build more american
products
in manufacturing automobiles
appliances and so much more
it's going to create jobs
it's going to help ease inflation
one of the reasons why automobiles cost
so much money these days and they're
responsible for one-third of all the
inflation that's calculated in the
market
is because they lack the semiconductors
to build the vehicles
intel's announcement
helps fix that problem
last week i called a meeting of ceos
from general motors ford microsoft and
other major corporations in america
mary barra
of general motors the chairman of the
board
the ceo i should say
announced a 7 billion investment in a
michigan manufacturing plant to
manufacture electric vehicles
it's going to create 4 000 new quality
jobs of prevailing wage
that's on top of the announcement last
year made by ford ceo jim farley who was
with us to invest 11 billion dollars
to make electric vehicles creating 11
000 new good paying jobs
look last friday i went to pittsburgh
where the pacific the union pacific
railroad
announced the largest purchase of
american battery electric locomotives in
history
built in area pennsylvania
built by american manufacturing workers
in western pennsylvania created even
more good-paying jobs and again to spin
off from that
these locomotives aren't just going to
be purchased in america
countries around the world because it's
going to be the best product they're
going to purchase them
american-made electric vehicles made in
erie pennsylvania good paying jobs
look we all know we're in competition
with the world
these announcements are the drumbeat a
job of the job resurgence unlike
anything we've seen in our history
and it didn't happen by chance
as a result of the economic plan i put
into action on day one
when i said it's going to be buy america
i'm delighted to keep it going
and expand what we've done
because we have a great opportunity
ahead of us to further progress make
progress where we've all beyond we've
already made look the house
representative just passed a few minutes
ago just before i walked over here
to provide
90 billion dollars
over 90 billion dollars for research and
development manufacturing and all those
elements of the supply chain needed to
produce end products right here in
america
so
we can keep delivering more
announcements like the one we've had
this past few weeks
another way we're boosting our economy
is by promoting competition
look
hamburger is uh you know
up for time fourfold almost many places
well guess what
meat
deprocessing
or shipping railroads other industries
are dominated by a few giant companies
that control the market they operate in
and over the years this domination of
the market by a smaller number of
companies smaller and smaller it's about
four in the meatpacking area has reduced
competition
squeezed out small businesses and
farmers
and many cases increased prices and
almost all increased prices for
consumers
look i'm a capitalist
but capitalism without competition is
not capitalism it's exploitation
so i'm going to continue to do
everything in my power
to work with the congress to make our
capital system work better provide more
competition and lower prices for
american consumers
and they're still going to do well
but that isn't going to be enough
we still need to ease the burden on
working families
by making everyday things more
affordable and accessible
look
average people are getting clobbered by
the cost of everything today
gas prices of the pump are up
we're working to bring them down but
they're up
food prices are up working to bring them
down as well
look i grew up in a family
where if the price for a gallon of gas
in the pump
went up significantly it was filled
by the family
i get it i understand
but these things are necessities but
that's not the totality of what family
needs
they still have to pay for child care
they still have to pay for prescription
drugs they still have to pay for health
care there's more than one way to help a
family when it comes to their standard
of living
we're going to work to bring down the
prices that are way up but guess what
guess what we're going to keep
strengthening the supply chain to bring
down the cost of every all these goods
but in the meantime there's a lot we can
do to give families a little extra
breathing room for example child care
families can spend fourteen thousand
dollars a year per child in some cases
in this country some cases less than
fourteen thousand dollars a year
for child care
our plan cuts in half most but most
families are paying helping their
budgets
helping keeping millions of
parents and especially women allowed to
go back to work because they can get
child care
or the cost of prescription drugs
like insulin
insulin costs about ten dollars to make
but for families that need the insulin
they're paying up to 650 a month on
average in some places and as high as a
thousand dollars a month
think about all those americans out
there with type 1 diabetes who need this
insulin to stay alive and stay healthy
or the 200 000 american children with
type one diabetes
think about being one of the parents
without the insurance or the money to
pay for that insulin
how do you look your child in the eye
who needs an insulin they have no idea
how they're going to figure out how to
pay for it
think about what it does to them
their self-esteem their dignity or their
ability to look their child in the eye
we capped the cost of insulin
at 35
on our plan
35 a month
companies are still going to make a
healthy profit
we can do that tomorrow with the stroke
of a pen
but we have a generation of so-called
for example sandwich generation
that is you have a young child and an
elderly parent and they both need help
and look
we can help them take care of mom and
dad and make it work
there's a program that allows us to and
on medicare
that someone can come and install a
handrail in the shower so mom doesn't
fall
to make sure they have what they need to
live with safety and dignity in their
home pick up the prescriptions
making occasional meals we can do all
that so when mom and dad put their head
on a pillow at night they can have peace
of mind that their elderly parents are
doing well and their children are okay
we're still going to work on gas prices
we're still going to work on the food
prices but in the meantime we can
deliver that piece of we can deliver
that peace of mind to the american
people and give them a little breathing
room
and by the way
proposals that i have out there
nobody earning less than four hundred
thousand dollars here would pay a single
additional penny in taxes
not a single penny
a lot of companies i've spoken to are
willing to pay a little more in their
corporate taxes
and their personal taxes to see that
happen
you've heard me say it a hundred times
you got 55 companies of the fortune 500
companies that paid zero tax the last
couple years
they made over 400 billion dollars
look
if we can do this without increasing the
deficit actually we've reduced the
deficit over 300
and 17 nobel arts and economics
came to me several months ago to say
that this plan would not only not raise
inflation it would ease long-term
inflationary pressures
look the bottom line is this
the united states is once again in a
position to not only compete with the
rest of the world but out-compete the
rest of the world once again
we can keep coming together and invest
in the backbone of america working class
and middle class folks
there's no limit to what we can achieve
so let's keep the raises the wages
rising and let's start lowering cost
our businesses are the best in the world
our workers are the best in the world
give them half a chance
they'll out-compete anyone anywhere in
the world
we can have a quality of life for
working people that they deserve at the
same time
and by the way the middle class when it
does well
when the working class does well
everybody does well
everything is better for the wealthy the
super wealthy and the slightly wealthy
nobody gets hurt
so let's face these challenges head on
let's keep building a better america
i want to thank you and god bless you
and may god protect our troops thank you
mr president
uh